never promised our people that we would
negotiate and net completely and bring
the negotiation to conclusion the first
two weeks I mean we the Greek people are
not that gullible and we are not that
cynical secondly we promised the end of
the troika the troika has finished the
track is not the three institutions we
never said anything about wanting to get
out of the eurozone our pledge to our
partners and the Greek people we're
going to do everything that is necessary
to stain the years and clearly that
means having relations with a central
bank which is the ACB we are this
country has been part of the Bretton
Woods process in 1944 so obviously our
relations with the IMF is ongoing and we
wanted to continue we've borrowed money
from them it must continue similarly we
are a member of the European Union the
relation with the Commission is going to
be continuing and actually improving but
that's not a troika let me tell you what
the try guys because the people of
Greece out there know exactly what it is
you don't and you don't have any reason
to know it because you didn't suffer the
indignity of these visits what we refer
to in this country is a trike is a team
of technocrats dispatched to this
country by the easy three institutions
to come here and impose upon the
government and the people a program that
was dead deflationary nature which had a
fig leaf of a reform program that never
had attacked the real sources of
rent-seeking this country and made a bad
thing worse this is finished that we
shall have a relationship and will be
audited by the institutions this is
something we not only that we want to
tolerate but I'm something we seek there
is why we extend the loan agreement was
not because we want to repudiate the
loans it because we wanted to repudiate
the conditionalities under which those
loans were given because these
conditionalities weren't allowing us to
grow sufficiently to repair that and
that is gone the idea about the promise
to renegotiate austerity that has
already been at attained in the sense
that for this year as we were saying
before the primary surplus target has
been waived these are all things that
the people are there on the street
understand the people are there on the
street do you know what the one thing
that they want is tell me it's not money
Sullivan jobs its dignity they want a
government that goes into the Eurogroup
that goes into a confident that goes the
European Union summit that discusses
matters with the IMF and ACB with a view
to re-establishing the very simple
notion that the Greek people must have a
say in the circumstances and in the
program and the measures that will get
us out of this Maya I that we have given
them